This lesson doesn't quite fit in with this unit, but the topic is important
enough that I'll cover it here. As we move the camera or objects through a
scene, models become larger and smaller. For very large scenes with many
objects, rendering everything in the scene at full detail can make us lose any
shred of interactivity. We've seen how there are limits to how large a texture
needs to be, in fact it's usually best if the texel to pixel ratio stays at
about one to one. More than that and the texture can just become a source of
noise. Choosing the proper data representation is part of a much wider topic
called level of detail. In this area of computer graphics, the focus is on how
to change an object's representation as its size on the screen changes. Methods
must balance tradeoffs between performance and quality. The two major areas
where level of detail techniques come into play are with meshes and textures.
Textures can be down sampled to create mid maps so that proper texture level
can be used for a scene. As a textured object gets farther away a smaller
texture on the mid map is needed. There also limits for how much memory a GPU
has available for texture storage. For very large data sets such as a city or
world map, it's impossible to save all the high resolution textures in memory
at the same time. Since we know that when an object is small on the screen, it
will need only a lower resolution texture. We can design our system to load
only the low resolution textures out of the mip chain. As we zoom in on a
particular object We can load the higher and higher resolution textures. At the
same time, we can be deleting the higher resolution textures for objects that
are now receding from view, or have been clipped off the screen entirely. As an
object gets smaller on the screen, we can also consider simplifying the
illumination equation. In other words using shaders with fewer instructions.
For example, if we get far away enough from an object, its displacement map may
add very little detail. Displacement maps help in particular by giving a more
realistic silhouette to an object. At a distance, these fine details are less
important. As an object gets smaller, switching from a displacement map to a
normal map then to no bump map at all saves considerable amounts of memory.
Mesh geometry itself can be thought of in the same terms. As a mesh gets
smaller on the screen, fewer vertices are needed to represent its details. For
objects that are tessellated into triangles, this means a smaller tessellation
factor can be given. For more complex objects that do not have a simple
tessellation factor, simplified meshes have to be either created by hand, or by
what's called the decimation algorithm. Such algorithms try to find the least
important triangles and patch up their areas with fewer triangles. Here's an
example by Paolo Cignoni using mesh lab, a powerful and free mesh manipulator.
This automatic techniques are effective but can run into problems with objects
such as faces, where the lips and eyes should be subject to less simplification
because of their importance. In mipmapping we interpolate between two textures
in the mip pyramid. With level of detail techniques for geometry, we can do the
same with what are called geomorphs. This technique can provide a smoother
transition between levels of detail, but at the cost of additional processing
and memory, which is in opposition to much of the point of using of level of
detail techniques in the first place. It's much more common to simply replace a
model with its simplified version when it becomes smaller on the screen. You
sometimes see a pop if the two versions of the model differ considerably. 3JS
supports this form of level of detail. In this demo, you can see different
versions of the sphere model being used depending on the distance from the
viewer. These were explicitly chosen by the programmer. If you look closely,
you'll see four different levels of detail.